voilà qu'on aille ensemble et dans ce
clip jaune mais à roland
c'est bien de leur fils band formes les
plus ordinaires
c'est parce qu'on m'a souvent demandé
pourquoi pourquoi avoir choisi sonia
rolland pour un pour mon clip et ça
n'avait rien à voir avec le fait qu'elle
a été miss france c'était gt gt comptant
le rwanda on est malheureusement connue
pour le génocide c'est vrai on ne
connaît pas le mandat pour pour un
athlète qui c'est qui qui s'est
distingué ou et en musique même chose on
a personne qui nous représente à
l'échelle internationale et ça me fait
plaisir de voir juste à l'échelle de la
francophonie de voir qu'avec quelqu'un
qui était qui était reconnu pour être
rwandaise
vous n'êtes que lui comment dans un bar
rwandais non la palmarès qu'à paris une
idée bien alors vous sonia votre père en
fait et france est un
il a quitté la france à la suite d'un
chagrin d'amour
et voilà il est allé refaire sa vie au
rwanda
et là il est tombé sur l'andra da et
voilà magnifique
ça me met très belle histoire d'amour
des femmes du pays non et c'est vraiment
non c'est vrai elle est très très belle
main et donc voilà vous êtes là alors
vous occupez d'associations pour enfants
du rwanda et qui d'ailleurs je voudrais
vous remercier quand même des trois fois
que je fais l'émission avec vous et
trois enfants vous en parler vraiment
oui on peut dire tout ce qu'on veut
c'est que vous avez fait à noël à noël
passe à la finale de la star academy ce
qui était papeete une émission qui
s'appelait le père noël n'est pas une
ordure
on a rigolé de l'argent pour votre
orphelinat numéro à paris enfin bon on
s'en fout on était content alors on vous
a vu fin novembre dans une fiction sur
sur arte oui et hormis deux cars loi de
rating en août a fait on va vous voir
bientôt donc dans un film de jean
marboeuf un long métrage oui je suis
contente
comme quoi avec le temps les choses
arrive quoi qui bombardé par vous êtes
un peu miss france pour pour devenir
comédienne voilà c'est vrai je joue si
pressé de s'en sortir mais c'est vrai
que l'étiquette de miss france me
défaire certaines fois alors cornaille
vous dites souvent dans les interviews
que vous n'avez pas encore rencontré le
samour faudrait quoi non j'ai confiance
j'essaye je suis en train de faire un
casting fonds morningstar disent oh non
c'est vrai nom mais je pense que c'est
oui j'ai eu des ratés quand on vous voit
tous les deux on se prend à rêver
c'est vrai ça maintenant d'empêcher des
dernières versions vie conjugale